[Music]
good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining this session on
DCP network performance monitoring and
diagnostics customer panel my name is
Shakira grewal I'm a product manager in
the cloud networking team and I lead
Google's efforts around network
performance monitoring and diagnostics
so I'm sure all of you are having a
great next so far and you have probably
attended sessions where you learn more
about google's cloud networking
solutions whether it's high performance
network global VPC is load balancers and
other capabilities we have while that's
great and that enables you to migrate
your workloads to Google cloud but on a
day to day basis when you are managing
your network as Network admins and
operators you want to make sure that you
can do that very very efficiently and
one of the big charters that we have
within Google cloud networking is to
make the day-to-day operations much much
easier and seamless right and I lead the
Charter to provide a set of tools and
capabilities for our customers to make
that easier to allow you to better map
monitor manage diagnose your network as
part of that we have been talking to a
lot of customers over the past few
months working closely with our user
research team and we have talked to over
20-plus customers so the goal of this
session is really to talk to you about
some of those learnings that we had from
those user interviews I have with me two
of our customers from mobile payment and
Cardinal health along with a partner can
take and gargy from our engineering
leadership team this is definitely a big
area of focus for us and we would love
to hear from more of you around your
pain points around in this space and and
partner with you so again this is the
panel and we'll introduce the panel
shortly again I want to thank all my
panelists today here
for joining with me in this session just
as a reminder hopefully you probably saw
this in other sessions as well we are
actually going to use Dory Q&A as well
along with if any of you have questions
please line up along the mic but you can
also go to the next app click the Dory
Q&A link there and actually post
questions on Dory and towards the end of
the session I'll be looking at Dory and
answering those questions but what it
also allows us is to actually answer
those questions even after the session
ok so feel free to post questions during
the session or even after the session
and we will definitely make sure to
respond to those questions so quick
agenda for today we will do again spend
quite a bit of time on panel discussion
learning from our customers I'll also
talk about some of the solutions we have
today for monitoring and diagnostics
within GCP and then can take who is one
of our partners we'll talk about how
they leverage some of GCP products to
provide visibility to our customers and
show a quick demo and then obviously you
leave enough time for audience Q&A so
with that in mind let's jump onto the
panel portion of the session and I'll
start with having each of the panelists
quickly introduce themselves so Edie
would you like to introduce yourself
adherence in your price architect for
Cardinal health for a large fortune 500
kind of company based in Dublin Ohio
Pelle Wong senior solution architect
from Global Payments we are a global
payment provider for white thank you
Justin or I burn director of solutions
engineering at Kent ik and we'll talk a
little later about who can take it and
what we do but as she's here mention or
a partner of Google's and happy to be
here Gargi Otto's also a partner in
crime that we share on the network
performance Diagnostics initiative that
and
and I managed the conflict distribution
pipeline that you don't see that is
hidden behind everything that you
configure and your external facing cloud
routing cloud router VPC peering so we
see a lot of problems or hear a lot from
our customers in terms of when they do
configurations what are their pain
points so here to hear from our
panelists on some of their pain points
and hear from you as well and we'll talk
about what we can do to address it thank
you everyone
let's jump right in so I'll start with
just asking like what are one or two key
pain points that you have our own
network performance monitoring and
diagnostics especially when you look at
your infrastructure or applications
running in cloud and maybe if you can
give some examples of some issues that
have happened or some outages that might
have happened and and maybe I'll start
with you here sure I've got the mics all
started well one of the problems is we
have a large staff and things are moving
very very quickly things are changing
all the time I'll give you a case in
point
recently a very skilled network engineer
was trying to work on a particular
problem between shared V pcs and that
kind of thing and he had totally
forgotten that we had multiple other V
pcs any post static route and one of the
B pcs which propagated on Prem routers
and took half routes and that wasn't
very nice that was one that was if he
had just stepped back and actually
looked at the configuration a little bit
better he would have found it he knew it
was there but it forgotten about it it
didn't scream at him before he put in
that configuration there was another one
that we had where we had database
release application release that we were
moving to the cloud and they put the
database in one V PC and they put the
application another V PC that's not very
good for performance so we're exiting
Iowa and going up to Chicago I'm back to
I
for every single database call and
significant latency so again in that
case it was it was on the console and
everybody looked at it including me and
we didn't see it
it wasn't intuitively obvious to us so
if if we had a clear methodology there
that would that would help us that's a
great example thank you thank you so the
challenge we're facing is we have
different workload we have a different
requirements which requires some of the
workload we put in a shared we PC some
they are in their own way PC so which
the challenge we are facing is we want
to know at any single point how many we
pcs were all within a particular way pcs
how many projects are associated
how many public IPS were on and within
each this if we change our firewall
rules how many we amps will get impact
so currently the check the challenges
were facing is that there are missing a
single pane of vo from network
monitoring perspective and those are one
of the challenges we're facing the other
things we're facing is if we want to do
some connectivity diagnosis I want we
want to know point-to-point what is our
the is there a connectivity between them
and what's the lane if there are what's
the latencies between them if there's no
connectivity what might be the issue so
those are the challenges were facing
today Thank You Kelly so Justin I mean
we heard from our customers but as a
partner I'm sure you talk to a lot of
customers so can you can you hear your
views on what what are you hear from
from customers yeah absolutely I think
you know when we talk to customers about
the the performance monitoring
Diagnostics challenges that they have in
their network and in their
infrastructure in Google cloud it
usually comes down to I'll call three
buckets and I think Edie and Kelly hit
on a number of those it's its cost so
using as example of traffic exiting one
VPC and coming back into another
performances is one aspect of that but
there's a cost to that as well so if you
optimize your applications and you have
the application of the database running
in the same VPC you avoid you know cost
of that traffic hair painting if you
want to phrase it that way the second
one is performance as admin and then the
third bucket that we hear a lot from
customers and security right how do I
know that the policies and the the
security posture that I think I have
both you know in my physical data center
as well as in my cloud are actually
being enforced is traffic getting
through that shouldn't be and am i
unintentionally blocking traffic that I
otherwise need to allow through as part
of my as part of my security
infrastructure because you know the
configuring ACLs and the VP C's can be
fairly complex as your is your
environment scales out so those are kind
of the three buckets of challenges that
we hear from from customers when we talk
to them thanks Justin so gargy I mean as
I mentioned at the beginning we have
actually talked to a lot of customers
and a lot of these themes we have heard
would you like to elaborate a bit on
maybe something else that that we have
customers yeah sure
so when Ed was talking and then Justin
as well about the performance thing that
is like a resounding thing that we've
heard from customers especially when
their performance deteriorates that they
would today don't have no way of knowing
why is it deteriorating where is the
bottleneck and so on so that has been a
resounding thing the other part of it is
the configuration changes and sometimes
if it is a syntax error then yes
obviously GCP will throw an error and
you will find out immediately but
syntactically your configuration could
be correct it could be accepted by the
VMS and everything is fine but then
suddenly there will be some impact on
your traffic of human it's little and
sometimes they don't even have
visibility because they do have multiple
network admins and security admins who
are both changing things so maybe
nothing changed in the networking
conflicts but the security admin came
and added an extra firewall rule or
something and then it goes all the way
up to troubleshooting your network and
then the app admins come and say hey
like
my service is not available to this XYZ
customer and go and see it's a network
problem so figuring out what the root
cause and the pain pointers and very
exactly something went wrong is the
resounding thing we've heard from many
of you
thanks gargy so I guess I mean if I were
to just summarize this I think we heard
a bit about security is obviously top of
mine how do you make sure you have the
right security posture and firewall
rules Kelly talked about configuration
changes and how do you make sure any
kind of connectivity issues especially
in a hybrid environment you can actually
make sure that any of the configuration
changes would not cause that
connectivity issue and it actually had a
very good example of somebody changing
that static routes and causing
connectivity to be broken so just by
show of hands I mean what percentage of
network outages and performance issues
happen because of configuration changes
anybody want to take a guess at the
number at the percentage here 80 anybody
else sixty actually that's very close I
mean the data is all like the data shows
that about 75% of network outages and
configuration happened because of
configuration related changes in it yeah
whatever you're closer so again I think
the point being that hopefully most of
you in the room are related to the
network team and you can realize that
configuration does cause a lot of
outages okay so moving on to the next
part maybe the next question I would
like to ask the panelist is about some
of the tools and solutions they are
using to address these challenges and
end do monitoring and diagnostics right
whether it's homegrown whether it's
Google provided solutions or whether
it's a third party so maybe Kelly I
would like to start with you here and if
you want to talk about some solutions
you use all right so today we are have
stacks of some solutions and tools
together to how
with monitoring and diagnosis from the
platform perspective we are turning on
older we PC flow locks which give us the
network performance information they
also provide security posture for us so
we know from a particular IP what the
resource is touching and at what time so
and those are at the V PC flow log level
we also turn on the firewall rule logs
as well so those give us the firewall
rules changing information and what is
art allowed what are the denied firewall
rules other than the platform provided
capabilities we also rely on the
traditional layer 2 layer 3 tools as
well like Chris wrote and also on top of
that we are we also want to get like
network topology information and those
are we are currently introduced a third
party to we we to use firewall logs very
heavily I'll give you an example
we have instances that are running on
premise and we bring them into the cloud
as we bring them into cloud we're trying
to do micro segmentation so we're using
a particular firewall rule that we apply
to all these instances and then we look
at the log traffic of that and then we
can lock down the instances with the
specific firewall rule logs that turned
out to be a significant amount of effort
that we had to develop these tools about
so having intelligent firewall log
management would be very helpful as well
as explaining that to application
developers who don't necessarily
understand how all their applications
work I'm sure our developers are unique
in that regard as well as the the
performance Kelly mentioned the
performance so we've actually install
third-party tools we're at different
points in our network we have
instrumentation points
so he can tell response times between
different segments and that turns out to
be really sensitive to our applications
two or three milliseconds seems to be
very sensitive at times okay thank you
so so apparently I mean you you are both
of you are using V PC firewall logs and
we physical logs and again just quick
poll among the audience how many of you
are using the PC flow logs and firewall
logs for monitoring or Diagnostics okay
so not a whole lot so again in the later
part of the presentation I'll actually
talk a bit more about VP flow logs and
firewall logs but that is actually we
see that a lot among our customers using
V PC flow logs and firewall Lords answer
- yeah and I'll actually talk about some
of the partner ecosystem we have in a
subsequent slide but definitely we are
again with Google we are obviously
providing you core capabilities as part
of the platform but we have an open
ecosystem where we have a lot of
partners that integrate with us we are
the logs or the API is so a lot of
customers do that ok so the next
question I would like to ask is if you
had a magic wand and if you were to wish
I would say one or two key capabilities
that GCP would provide you that would
make the life of of you as a network
admin operator Enterprise Architect
easier what would those one or two
things would be and Kelly maybe I would
so I would I want to have a platform
provide me of view which this wheel can
even the operator the operation team
they don't have there not be a very
skilled network engineer they can come
into this tool and they are from this
platform provided
vo there they can find the topology
information so they can see what are the
VP sees way on within each VP see what
my topology wheels and inside this we PC
instead per subnet
how many VMs are associated with how
many public eye peas are associated with
a PC how many public IPS are associate
under our account and also which we have
this vo capabilities we can monitoring
the network performance instead of I go
into the web PC flow logs we have that
information in the vlog but it's very
time consuming to get that information
today so if we have this vo that'll be
ideal for operation team in in case
there's incidents happening they can do
the first phase trade without involving
a whole bigger team and also the if
these two provided by diagnostic
capability so they can provide a
point-to-point connectivity information
and tell what are the latencies are and
those will be the things I think of my
top wish list it I have to echo a lot
what Kelly said one of the other things
about the performance is that you can
use that as a canary as to whether it's
something's going wrong for example if I
know that I normally have traffic going
from US central to you know Europe or
whatever and it's supposed to take so
much time and then all of a sudden that
starts inching up I know that I'm doing
something somewhere that could indicate
a failure and now we always want the
network to be highly resilient but I
want to be able to detect that and Al
are not necessarily alarm but give trend
analysis so I can understand when
something has gone
so sometimes those are very very subtle
signals and if you don't look at it all
the time I don't know about you but I
don't look at all these reports all the
time if you don't look at it all the
time you can miss these things was it
one point two seconds or was at one
point seven seconds I don't remember
right and so having a tool that would be
very sensitive in that regard the other
one is in the firewall rules when
somebody's going to put something in
knowing what the effect is before it
happens would be a really good thing to
have before I go change a static route
knowing before it happens that I'm gonna
have a BGP propagation problem that
would be really really nice to know so I
think you know with with a lot of
capabilities that Google can do they're
in a great position to help us with that
great great thank you so I think what I
heard about just to summarize some of
the things right I think Kelly mentioned
about getting a topology view may be
getting better performance metrics right
off the out-of-the-box as opposed to
mining lot of data in mine a lot of
information and I think it swishes how
they can manage configuration changes
which is even before things happen so
and I know
Gargi here has the magic warrant I think
gargy do you want to like address some
of like what we have heard from the
customers and maybe talk a bit about at
least how Google is looking at
addressing some of these problems sure
sure so obviously like I mentioned we
have VPC logs and VPC flow logs firewall
logs that help you troubleshoot your
problems and help us troubleshoot if
those logs are enabled but it looks like
not many of you have been using it so
far but some of our partners including
some here they also shared that they use
have those logs and then they have write
scripts on top of those logs to find -
fine fine tune like and identify where
is the needle in the haystack but one of
the things that we've been hearing is
like finding the needle in the haystack
where the Google can help you with that
and that's exactly what we are going to
do because there is
a lot of information like Kelly said
it's hidden and it's hard to go and
navigate because you don't even
anticipate that oh this thing under this
tree would have some information in
there so that is definitely something
can help but one thing I'd like to ask
all of you because we've heard so much
about configuration problems from all
our customers and Justin here as well
how many of you are afraid to make
configuration changes or have conflict
change as a pain point like if we can
have a show of hands is that one of your
biggest pain points how many of you here
have that that you'd like to have more
okay slowly raising the hands so that is
an area definitely that we are looking
into and if you are interested in
solving that pain point do connect with
us offline or she sure is definitely
driving this effort from the product
side we also have a UX research lead
back there who's engaging with a lot of
customers and finding out their pain
points so that we can feed it into the
products that we are building that is
definitely an area or magic one and
again I think as we said right and some
of the pain points that you've heard
about whether its topology providing
better performance information or
allowing our customers to diagnose
connectivity issues due to configuration
or enabling them to make configuration
changes more confidently so we
understand all of these pain points we
would like to actually hear more from
any of you who has insights into those
use cases but again watch out and we are
we are looking at these problems and how
we can solve these problems one of the
things is also customers ask us whenever
there is a problem there is an app admin
who separate from the network admin so
they say they'll just tell me whether
it's an application problem or isn't led
to a problem networking problem so even
getting to that point it takes them time
before they figure that out and
obviously person hours so that is
another area that we can help you with
so do connect with us offline if these
are some of your pain points
so thank you everyone I think that was
great insights and great feedback and I
hope all of you attending could
hopefully relate to some of these pain
points and could see how Google is
looking to address this so I want to
actually kind of change gears a little
bit and talk about what are the existing
solutions that that are available today
that a lot of our customers use and
actually you can go back and use as well
right so one of the key capabilities
that we have is is VPC flow logs and
again the idea here is that we record a
sample of the network flows that are
sent or received by the VM instances
those flows are aggregated every five
seconds and actually with a new
capability that's currently in beta you
can actually configure that interval and
a lot of our customers use VPC flow flow
logs for variety of use cases the first
one is obviously network monitoring
where they can look at the flow data
look at kind of who are the top talkers
where is the traffic coming from even
use that data for optimizing their
expenses or network security again lot
of customers pipe VC flow logs to maybe
a sim solution and look at whether the
connections are happening from legit I P
addresses or not so then they can apply
the right kind of policies you can view
these VPC flow logs in a stack driver
and then also you can export it to cloud
pub/sub or bigquery or a third party
solution like like service and one of
the key capabilities that actually a lot
of you who might have used we busy flow
logs have asked is around how can you
reduce the volume of vbc flow logs so
again we have some new controls
available now which is in beta to
actually allow you to reduce the vbc
flow log volume so you can control the
time interval in which the aggregation
happens so by default it happens every
five seconds but now you can set it to
30 seconds a minute 10 minutes or 15
minutes
similarly for log entry sampling so we
sample so when we write the logs to the
database there is a sampling that
happens and by default
the sampling ratio is 0.5 or 50% but now
actually you can control it you can set
it to 100% or on the extreme and you can
set it to 0%
so that's another control that's
available along with metadata
annotations where the notion is that
when we write we busy flow logs we
actually write the source and
destination VM instance names we write
the geographical information in terms of
regions so all of that you can actually
choose to not annotate your VPC flow
logs because your use case might be
simply to know the IP addresses so so
those are the controls that are
available to you and the other key
capabilities is firewall locks so this
allows you to actually audit verify and
analyze the effects of your firewall
rules right so you can actually
understand if a firewall rule that you
have it is doing what it's intended to
do so for example if it's blocking the
traffic that you want it to block right
so you enable these firewall rules
logging on a per rule basis and unlike
we see flow logs these are not sampled
so these are available for every
connection and you can see them in a
stack driver logging or or exported to
pub/sub or bigquery in addition to
logging within the cloud console we also
have very very rich meant monitoring
capabilities so on the service pages and
I am taking an example of VPN here if
you go to the VPN page you can actually
see some key information for monitoring
out-of-the-box right you can see what is
the VPN tunnel status if it's green as
an if established or it might be red
which means then it's not seeing an
incoming packets this is some basic
level of monitoring that you see on the
service pages and similarly you will see
for interconnect but then we publish lot
of metrics that you can see in the stack
driver so stag driver has out-of-the-box
dashboards for example if you go to
resources under stack driver and the
services VPN we actually are now
publishing metrics such as tunnel status
received by its packet loss of which is
drop packets which is one of the key
metrics that the service
look at and then you can set alerts on
on these metrics and depending on the
thresholds you want so you can say if my
packet drop is less than it's more than
whatever point zero one person I want to
get an alert so but these these
dashboards are available out of the box
and last but again very important
we have a rich partner ecosystem so to
some of the questions that somebody was
asking earlier we have integrations with
sim partners for VPC flow logs and
firewall logs so you can send data to
sumo logic or Splunk solutions a lot of
customers use next-generation firewalls
such as Palo Alto or for tonight or
checkpoint where again that's sitting in
line and it has full visibility of the
traffic that's flowing through your
network and compliance reasons we have
again a lot of vendors or partners who
integrate with VPC flow logs and again
you'll hear from one of the partners can
take in a minute but that's another
integration that's available so with
that I think it's a good segue into the
last section here where I would invite
Justin to talk about can take and show
us a quick demo all right Thank You
Shishir so for those who aren't familiar
with Kentico I'll be brief on this but
just a kind of a quick overview about
who Kinta key is we're about a
five-year-old startup that's based here
in in San Francisco you know we've seen
good success over the last five years
across we call digital enterprise as
well as the service provider community
this is how our platform is built so
it's just you mentioned that the Google
VPC flow logs can be exported to a pub
sub bus and then basically you configure
your VPC is to send those logs to that
bus and then you configure our system to
it to listen to to subscribe to that
conversation
pull those flog flow logs back into our
system
and then we enrich that with a lot of
different pieces of context so you know
flow logs out out of the box from Google
give you a lot of good information it's
just you're mentioned around what's the
VM source what's the zone source what's
the project source there's a lot of good
rich information that's in there but we
we also have some some additional
metadata that will enrich with as well
things from kubernetes or sto if you're
running those type of service mesh
setups we can find out a little bit more
information about pods and and nodes and
so forth and then once we have those
logs into our system I'll give you some
examples of what some of the UI
screenshots would look like we give you
all kinds of insights about what your
traffic looks like in both our UI is of
it as well as give you an API that's
available to pull that data out if you
want to integrate it with another system
and then all kinds of proactive
notifications and alerts that you can
use to find out proactively about
changes in your in your network
environment in your V pcs so what are
some of the use cases and why why would
people use kantak you know and a lot of
it comes down to the persona of the user
right so for our our network operations
and our network engineering teams kind
of to the point that Guardi made earlier
the age-old question is that the
application or is it the network right
and so you know using using kantak and
looking at the the flow logs and finding
out am i seeing an increase in latency
for just a single application all the
applications in a single V PC can give
me some clues and some indicators into
is my network performance is it a
network performance issue or is an
application performance issue which is
really powerful to our so our network
operations our network engineering users
on the sec ops side he comes back to I
think what I was mentioning earlier
about security is the security posture
that I believe I have enforced actually
working the way that I believe it is in
you know once my configuration gets
applied am i allowing things through
that shouldn't be my blocking things
that I that I mean to let allow through
on the SRA and DevOps I there's a lot of
trying to figure out what applications
are talking to what other applications
as I mentioned we have a rich API that
allows you to
some of this some of this data out which
allows you to automate a lot of your
systems to do some automation built on
top of changes to network traffic
patterns or certain traffic patterns
that you see in your environment and
then for the executives we have sort of
a higher level dashboard so they can get
a view of how many VP C's do I have how
much traffic is coming in and out of
them how is my cloud network performing
you know just some screenshots as
examples that might be interesting to
network engineering and network
operations is what we call a sin key
diagram and this shows coming out of one
particular project it's spread across us
well us east and us West what are the
destination IP addresses that that
traffic is flowing to and what is the
application in this particular case of
course it's a secure web application so
as a network engineering or a network
operations user I can quickly see how my
how many network is performing for
security operations again like I said
it's it's really about what are their
data exfiltration events going on is my
security policy being applied the way
that I think it's being applied this is
where the proactive notifications come
in really useful as I can get
notifications when there's a new event
that takes place in the network and then
drill down and get a lot more detail
about what that network event is latency
so this is something that is a really
powerful feature that Google enables by
putting latency information and each one
of the flow augs they export now I can
look at on a per application basis what
is my what is my latency and am I seeing
an increase in the latency of my
application so in this particular
example here on the slide you see just
one application out of many has a huge
spike in its latency so that gives me an
indicator that likely this is a network
or a an application latency issue and
not a network issue and so I can try and
defend myself as a networking guy and
say no it's not the VPC network and
that's something to do with your
application and then like I said it's
for the executives a dashboard that
shows a lot of different views of how is
the network performing at a high level
how much traffic do I have where is it
coming from where is it going to
and how much is it costing me so as an
example more concrete we here at Kent ik
have application we call the sock shop
that's running on GCP so this is a an
example workload it's a micro-services
containerized application that has
various pieces to it it has a card it
has a catalog and so you know as a user
that runs this ecommerce website there
are a couple things that I can look at
so the first thing that I look at is a
dashboard that shows me all of my V PC
traffic for this application shows me my
traffic zone to zone region to region
project project so I can kind of see how
are the various pieces of my application
running and to Ed's point earlier I can
try and look for do I have in
efficiencies and where my workloads have
been placed do I have the cart or the
catalog running in a different VPC than
what I have my database running in and
and you know is that something that I
could better optimize and then this is
another view that gives us some some
information about this micro services
application that's running it's showing
me the various pieces of the application
and what's talking to what so my
front-end web site for example talking
back to the to the sock shop the catalog
talking to the cart there's a lot of
different interactions that are
happening in that application and I can
see how each one of those maps to each
other you know
whether that be bits per second whether
that be packets per second or even
latency information I can drill down and
get a lot more information about how the
application is performing and look for
inefficiencies in how that application
is performing
[Music]